[Musique]
et notre promenade nous amène avec
jacques prévert et joseph kosma jusqu'au
feuilles mortes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais tant du soulier des jours
heureux où l'on jette un ami en est le
sous le brûlant qu'aujourd'hui les
feuilles mortes se ramassent t'appelles
tu vois je ne pense pas lève les sons et
les réseaux ci est le pendant les
enfants
dans la nuit froid nous
[Musique]
tu vois ans
je ne pas oublier
oh
un changement qui ne ressent
toi tu m'aimais
je t'aimais nous vivions
[Musique]
toi qui m'aimait
moi qui te plaît
[Musique]
ce décès tout
s'en venait
deux bombes
[Musique]
la mène et ça ce sur nous ce n'est pas
m
le déni
je nie
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les enfants qui s'aiment s'embrassent le
mou contre les portes de la nuit et les
passants qui passe les désigne du doigt
allez sans qui ce sens là pour personne
et c'est seulement leur ombre qui
tremblent dans
excitant la rage de vincent graveleau
fini
coffret les deux mamelles péri les
enfants qui s'aiment dessous la personne
et ils le sont
d'ailleurs
bien plus loin que la de vie bien plus
encore dans l'éblouissante qualité de
leurs premières armes
[Musique]
à l'enterrement d'une feuille morte que
six cargos sans vent ils ont la copie
noir du creps autour des cornes
ils s'en vont dans le noir un très beau
soir d'automne est là quand ils arrivent
c'est déjà le printemps les feuilles
étaient mortes sont toutes au ressuscité
et les deux escargots sont très
désappointé mais voilà le soleil le
soleil qui leur dit prenez mais prenez
la peine la peine de vous asseoir prenez
un verre de bière c'est le coeur vous en
dit prenez si ça vous plaît l'autocar
pour paris il partira ce soir
ne prenez pas le deuil
c'est moitié volts et savoir si le blanc
de l'oeil depuis
sans lady les histoires de sûr que c'est
triste mais pas joli reprenez vos pleurs
les couleurs de la vie alors
toutes les bêtes les arroser les plantes
se met à chanter à chantérac itf la
vraie chanson vivante la chanson de
l'été et tout le monde de boire tout le
monde de trinquer c'est un très jolie
histoire un joli soir d'été
et les deux escargots s'en retournent
chez eux ils s'en vont très émus ils
s'en vont très heureux
comme ils ont beaucoup bu tu te bats ne
tue pas mais
dans le ciel
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas ma maison je ne sais pas
qui allait je suis entré comme ça un
jour
et elle personne
seulement des piments rouges accrochés
aux murs blancs je suis resté longtemps
dans cette maison
personne n'est venu mais tous les jours
et tous les jours je vous ai a tenté
je ne faisais rien c'est à dire rien de
sérieux quelquefois le matin jeux
poussaient des cris d'animaux je
gueulais comme un homme de toutes mes
forces
est cela me faisait plaisir et puis je
jouais avec mes pieds
c'est très intelligent lépi
ça vous emmène très loin quand vous
voulez aller très loin et puis quand
vous ne voulez pas sort des 1 et reste
là il vous tiennent compagnie
m
et quand il ya la musique ils dansent on
ne peut pas danser sans elle
peut-être d'être comme l'homme les si
souvent pour dire des choses aussi bête
que bête comme ses pieds
[Musique]
gai comme un pinson
enfin ce n'est pas gai il est seulement
gay quand il est gay triste quand il est
triste uni gay ni tristesse qu'on sait
ce que c'est un pansement
d'ailleurs c'est l'homme qui a appelé
cet oiseau leur comme ça passe on parle
sont passons
pain
saute
comme c'est curieux les noms
martin hugo victor de son prénom
bonaparte napoléon ii sont prenantes
pourquoi comme ça et parle comme ça un
troupeau de bona par an passent dans le
désert
l'empereur s'appelle dromadaires il
acheva le casser des tiroirs de course
au loin gallopin homme qui n'a que trois
prénoms il s'appelle kim tomtom
un peu plus loin il ya n'importe qui est
beaucoup plus loin encore il ya
n'importe quoi et puis qu'est ce que ça
peut faire tout ça
dans ma maison tu viendras je pense à
autre chose mais je ne pense qu'à ça et
puis quand tu seras entrer dans ma
maison tuant lèvres à tous tes vêtements
tu restera immobile
avec ta bouche rouge comme les piments
rouges pendu sur le mur blanc
et puis tu te couchera je me coucherai
près de toi voilà dans ma maison qui
n'est pas ma maison
curial bras
un homme avait un chien un chien qui
l'appelaient amour l'homme lui donnait à
manger le chien le lait chez l'homme
caresser le chien il le lèche est aussi
quand il était seul parfois même il
aboyait un peu pour lui faire plaisir à
vos chiens c'est mon chien c'est mon
amour disait l'homme c'est mon homme a
broyé l'amour mais un jour triste triste
triste jour l'homme s'aperçut de
certaines choses
sauf qu'en ce que je mangeais meilleur
je lui donne moins à manger sauf s'il
s'en aperçoit il se soit vrae moi je
resterai la seule sans mon chien mon
amour mon amour à moi de le tuer et puis
je ne mangerai rien ne sera perdu
et il le tue et ils le mangent mais à la
fin du repas faisant le beau et sortent
en 2d sous la table apparaît le fantôme
du chien
machinalement l'homme jette à l'ombre un
os un os mais le fantôme du chien dans
son super se trouve très bien et n'a pas
faim il n'a pas faim dos il regarde
l'homme d'un bon oeil se jettent dessus
et le mange
puis il sort de la salle à manger en se
disant en se dandinant amour tout à fait
vivant il reprend ses couleurs et son
comportement
puis gilles cours amour ils courent
amour dans la ville à la recherche d'un
autre maître amour pour faire le beau
amour pour se faire caresser amour pour
se faire battre
amour pour se faire tuer amour pour
dévorer dévorer dévorer et bien ce texte
ils s'appellent les enfant de bohème
voyez que le titre n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'ils racontaient par jacques
prévert et ce texte il appartient un
recueil qui vient d'être édité par les
éditions gallimard qui s'appelle soleil
de nuit ce sont les textes écrits par
jacques prévert entre 1935 et 1977
je souhaite que ce petit exercice de
style
auquel je viens de me livrer vous est
donné le goût de vous replonger dans
préfère
[Musique]
c'est ce qui fait cette main est le 4
était beaucoup y est ça qu il ya des
trucs qui cèdent du terrain
le gars me fait beaucoup mieux que ça q
quand tu sais la vache le diable pas la
corrida mais quand tu fais là internet
je me fais le joli coup que ce qui peut
se passer beaucoup qui veulent bien
peut-être mieux fait la machine le
diable pas la corrida dit quand tu fais
là
[Musique]
que fait ce qu'il veut de senna mais le
câble fait beaucoup mieux que tu t'es
laissé dès cet été
[Musique]
la paix
le temps
vous avez vous prévert écrivait en
anglais enfin vous allez voir c'est
l'anglais et son vrai père
oui c'est une chanson
intitulé
en somme
[Musique]
wayne wildcat hypothéqua si peu d tox
il pleut des boys étaient 15 il pleut
des rats et des
des chiens sapa
tokyo
oh
comment
pendant un an
m
flatté belote
[Musique]
oui oui oui
et plus
plus plus
et puis
l'étude a fui
cela fait cher
mentant
mashal
de tels montants
m
[Musique]
one way we got him avec un triple bogey
il n'oubliait pas du 15 mai
et
un chat aucun
[Musique]
oui oui oui oui
et plus et puis
et plus
et puis là dessus
non
sunshine
de temps en temps
chat
je vais faire comme un messie à bonn
gérer choisir il a choisi des chantiers
moi parce que c'est non non non je parle
j'ai réduit un poème
ouais je voudrais tant que tu te
souviennes c'etait un
là où nous étions amis en ces temps là
la vie était plus belle et le soleil
puis bien qu'aujourd'hui les feuilles
mortes se ramassent à la pelle
pourquoi je peux pas oublier les
feuilles mortes se ramassent à la pelle
les souvenirs et les regrets
[Musique]